(laughing)
- Laughter is like a
spiritual practice for me.
I laugh everywhere I go.
What I believe, the world
can be a better place
if more and more people start laughing.
(laughing)
(chanting)
My name is Madan Kataria.
I'm a medical doctor and
creator of Laughter Yoga.
(laughing)
It's time to laugh.
Laughter Yoga is a unique concept
where anyone can laugh
for no reason at all.
(laughing)
We don't need to rely on jokes,
sense of humor or comedies.
Laughter unwinds the
negative effects of stress
and makes our immune system stronger.
And brings more oxygen
to our body and brain.
(laughing)
The reason we call it Laughter Yoga
is it's a combination
of laughter exercises
with deep breathing techniques from yoga.
Scientifically, our body
doesn't know the difference
between real laughter and fake laughter.
We will still get the
same health benefits.
(laughing)
I created Laughter Yoga because
my life was very stressful.
Being a leader of a health magazine
and a medical practitioner,
I could not find any
relief from the stress.
Then I found a breakthrough
that there is lot of medicine in laughter.
Based on this idea I created
laughter as a form of exercise.
(laughing)
I wake up at four in the
morning and the first thing I do
is I laugh for 30, 40 minutes everyday.
I'm laughing in my daily routine,
laughing with my staff.
(laughing)
Everybody calls me, nobody says me hello.
Hoho-haha.
(laughing)
I'm laughing on Skype; I'm
teaching Laughter Yoga.
One day I'm going to die laughing.
(laughing)
Very good, very good, yay.
My mission in life is to
create social laughter clubs,
which are free for everyone in the world.
(guitar music)
When we laugh in a group it
becomes real and contagious,
it becomes easier to laugh.
Now we have more than
16,000 laughter clubs
in 100 countries.
(laughing)
When you find happiness
with laughter practice,
the perception of the algorithm changes.
We can create happiness within ourselves.
(laughing)